just just go with Jamie call the picture
if I'm using my special host 4.5 million
I don't know oh man damn
don't be [ __ ] lame dude you're right
he's really living did you think the
Chappelle monologue was Auntie Sam I
didn't see it I don't know I assume it
was fine I didn't catch it was a comic
because there's no problem at all I
don't know I liked it I thought the
whole thing in the beginning was
hilarious yeah where he reads this thing
so who just wants anti-Semitism in any
way shape or form yeah and that Kanye
West is how you buy yourself some time
yeah that's very funny I've announced
anti-Semitism in all its forms
all right
and I stand with my friends in the
Jewish community
and that
Kanye
is how you buy yourself some time
Ferguson genius
20 people and then everyone's argue
about the 20 people that are fake okay
no one cares no one cares well it's a
we're living in a weird world where
everybody can have an opinion and if
there's a thing that is in somehow way
shape or form connected to anything
controversial this is going to be people
to get upset about Dave Chappelle is the
number one stand-up talking about Jews
today I give you a pass it's over you're
not answering it is over go on with your
life Dave Chappelle 4.5 million
it's a lot of views that's worse than
the [ __ ] picture
I always lost he's lost in the world of
success and mushrooms you gotta drink
past these shrooms man